Vladimir Putin says he's Banning oil
exports to select nations from February
the ban will apply to those countries
that implemented a cap on what they were
willing to pay for Russian oil earlier
this month the G7 Nations the EU and
Australia all pledged to pay no more
than 60 a barrel from the 5th of
December to sanction Russia over its
illegal invasion of Ukraine Russia
started the month as the world's second
biggest exporter of oil
energy analyst Tom O'Donnell is on the
line for us Tom you're skeptical that
this will have any significant effect
why is that
well good evening thank you for having
me Daniel um look
um already the European Union it's
rather stunning they refuse they will no
longer as of December 5th take any
Seabourn oil from Russia which is the
bulk of it and United States and Canada
already are doing that
so Russia is mainly selling what it
can't sell in Europe they're selling as
much of it as they can to India China
and turkey
and those countries are already paying
Russia well below the market price 25 28
dollars per barrel below the usual price
for Russian oil
so just like right now the price cap
doesn't have much effect because 60
dollars a barrel is above what Russia is
getting from those countries so too this
doesn't you know there's no more
countries that are obeying a price cap
that aren't already not taking Russian
oil so it has very little effect right
now this is a bit of a chess game being
set up by both sides that will now
develop step by step in my opinion okay
but a Russian Economist explained it
like this the lower the volume is in the
market the higher the price will be so
Russia will be compensated by the rise
in price of oil which will be paid by
other customers like China or India as
you said considering that Global prices
should rise to as a result so what
you're saying is
um this plan this is how it should work
it's just not as simple as that
yes let me give you an example well of
course the example you just gave me in
the limit if you think of your Calculus
class in the limit that goes to zero
okay because they're not selling any oil
um so Russia will certainly be selling
less oil over time because that was a
huge amount of oil that went to the
European Union and on February 5th the
European Union will stop taking refined
products Diesel and so forth which was a
very important market now to move that
oil that would take maybe a week or so
to come from the Baltic ports of Russia
into Europe now we'll take two three and
more like four weeks to go all the way
around to China and India they need that
many more time ships and the problem is
you can't get insurance on those ships
generally real you know sort of uh World
Standard Insurance unless you get it
from companies in the European Union and
the United States and Britain and those
countries will not give insurance will
not allow it anymore for Russian oil
unless it's sold under the price cap
so even if you know this is a problem uh
so India and China aren't going to agree
with the price cap but because there's a
price cap they're saying to Russia you
know you can't sell your oil to Europe
anymore you can't sell it over a certain
price elsewhere so we won't go along
with the cap but you better give us a
lower price and that seems to be what's
happening and that's what the Biden
Administration intended okay and now
Russia's hoping that the EU will be hit
by this so how is the EU coping at the
moment with this price cap with its
shift away from Russian oil
um with the oil it's going I mean gas is
another matter they there's a they
Russia has this level over Europe but in
oil it seems to be so far going pretty
well it's being handled pretty well uh
we don't see any great spikes in the
price of oil right now of course we all
know what's coming is a recession in
Europe everybody's predicting this
um and and China con I mean they're
trying to come out of covet eventually
they're going to have a big demand for
oil and gas but for right now they have
a bit of a mess as we all know
um so for right now
um it looks like the demand is going to
be soft going forward and there's not
going to be any significant shock
getting into next year many analysts
predict the price could go Fairly High
um that is possible if demand picks up
and
um you know the Russian oil can't go
there but in the long run there's plenty
of oil in the world there's plenty of
oil in the Middle East there's plenty of
oil and you know but that takes a while
okay Plenty much to look forward to for
2023 then lots of drama there in the
energy markets I bet Tom O'Donnell thank
you very much for that
thank you